au mois d'avril mai
en omaha découvert une petite maladie
qui arrive aux gens qui fument qui sont
la cause des fumées
pendant des années on m'a dit arrête de
fumer réduit à neuf mais j'ai fini
beaucoup
et puis on m'a trouvé un petit cancer du
poumon
c'est après fois que j'en parle falloir
mars avril on a commencé à faire un
scanner parce que j'avais une bronchite
qui passait pas avril ça ressemblait
bien un cancer mais pet scan le pet scan
c'est un examen du corps en entier au
scanner confirme qu'il ya un petit
cancer du poumon est donc ça s'est fait
au mois de mai
alors ça sert dans le documentaire qui
passera le 9 décembre
nathalie donc comment tu as appris ce ce
vous en cuir nous le nom de nous
l'expliquer avec jean-pierre quand il a
passé tous ses examens non c'est moi
j'ai juste poussé parce qu'il avait une
bronchite sans arrêt donc c'est normal
on est tous et beaucoup donc j ce serait
peut-être temps que tu ailles faire de
nouveau des examens et puis donc il a
fait un premier examen et puis il disait
il ya quelque chose qui est pas très
près clair et puis comme il raconte il a
fait un pet scan & lamont le verdict est
tombé
donc ce qu'on a fait c'est que
[Musique]
au début on pouvait pas faire
l'opération on dit que ce n'était pas
possible de faire l'opération passe d
extrêmement dangereux et
donc moi j'ai insisté pour qu'on aille
voir d'autres médecins dans un autre
hôpital parce que je
je voulais savoir si on pouvait l'opérer
ou pas est bon c'est à l'hôpital
pompidou et heureusement ils nous ont
dit si on peut on peut l'opérer il n'y a
aucun danger et moi je voulais je
voulais faire absolument l'opération
parce que quand vous faites l'opération
vous retirez la moitié du poumon et
pouvait analyser il pouvait savoir ce
que c'est comme comme cancer donc c'est
très important de savoir ce que c'est
comme cancer parce que avant on disait
qu'on voulait il voulait juste faire de
la radiothérapie mais surprise et la
radiothérapie on savait pas ce que
c'était comme cancer donc c'était un peu
plus chiant et donc ça s'est passé au
mois de juillet on a fait on est passé
trois semaines à l'hôpital et s'est fait
opérer tout s'est très bien passé et
puis ben là au mois de septembre ça
attaque et l'autre tout le monde donc
par contre c'était un peu plus chiant
parce que
c'était un peu plus gros et et
donc là c'est clair qu'on peut passer
par une opération parce que c'est
beaucoup trop lourd donc là il fait de
la radiothérapie et puis puis la moral
d'acier et puis on est au près de lui
toute sa famille et puis et puis se bat
et puis comme on dit jamais deux sans
trois on a fait un chacun un cancer et
puis ma y en a un autre qui vient puis
le mot cancer ça veut pas dire la mort
automatiquement soulève annoncé qu à vos
enfants comment tous les doublures non
c'est surtout moi c'est ce que moi j'ai
toujours l'habitude de parler avec mes
enfants comme pour le cancer de la
prostate j'ai toujours prévenu mes
enfants parce que j'ai pas envie de leur
mentir c'est pas la peine puis
maintenant ils sont assez assez grands
aussi et puis
c'est pas la peine d'avoir des mensonges
dans les familles pour combattre cette
maladie je pense qu'il faut quand on
essaie bien de le dire comme ça on n'a
plus besoin d'y penser je dis pas je dis
je dis pas on a autre chose à penser et
puis non mais ils ont bien pris puis les
enfants me font confiance moi je leur
disais exactement tout comment ça se
passe et puis on a réussi pour la
prostate on a aussi on a on a gagné
contre apostats on a gagné contre le
premier poumon donc le deuxième poumon
je vois pas pourquoi on gagnerait pas et
puis bah le mot cancer comme j savait
pas dire la mort et puis vous savez
malheureusement bon ben c'est jean
pierre pernaut mais tous les jours il ya
des gens qui entendent qui
quelqu'un proche qui a guéri cancer
c'est pas le seul malheureusement alors
jean pire dans don c'est un bâton vous
nous l'avez dit et il explique qu'il a
aussi envisagé le pire dans ce
documentaire y
avait pensé au pire non je te crois pas
non bien évidemment quand on a un ennui
on pense à bon et si je revenais pas et
si par hasard je glissais dans un
escalier à l'hôpital ça peut arriver
aussi
ils vont donc c'est de préparer d'autres
un truc mais sans plus
bien évidemment bien évidemment quand il
est sage du mans c'est sûr parce que
c'est sûr que c'est vrai qu'on me dit ah
j'ai eu un cancer de la prostate ah bah
oui bah moi aussi j'en ai eu un puits à
tout il avait le sourire et maintenant
quand il annonce que j'ai un cancer des
poumons ah ouais d'accord s'est tout de
suite bien sûr comme j'ai dit à jean
pierre c'est clair moi aussi j'ai fait
une drôle de tête cancer des poumons
c'est c'est violent on le savait
mais moi je dis que la force de
caractère il faut il faut faut se battre
sont pas baisser les bras il faut être
positif à fond dans la tête et puis là
plein de soutien et puis disent quoi les
médecins pour l'instant on peut rien
dire encore parce que l'on donc il fait
la radiothérapie et au mois de janvier
aux frappes et scan pour voir où ça en
est et là seulement pour elle
ça évolue quand est-ce qu'on peut pas
savoir tout de suite là du coup
aujourd'hui bon alors jean-pierre
aujourd'hui il continue ses activités
oui voilà il y à son coin
non mais justement c'est bien s'est il
est content de bosser un peu à droite à
gauche pour lci faire les magazines tout
ça
non non non c'est bien et quand tu me
doit se reposer et se repose mais non il
a un caractère d'enfer et la poignée bah
tu veux bien non mais c'est parce que la
télé c'est quelque chose de très intime
pourquoi avoir décidé de d'en parler
dans un documentaire ou même d'en parler
alors mois déjà au démarrage justement
c'était un coup de gueule parce que j'en
ai marre justement que les gens à cause
du coc vide ne vont pas faire des
examens n'ose pas aller dans les
hôpitaux et franchement si jean-pierre
n'avait pas été parce que à part une
bronchite il avait rien d'autre
mais les gens ne vont pas sûr d'y aller
on pense qu au lido coville est
malheureusement il ya plein de gens ils
vont apprendre qu'ils ont des cancers
parce qu'ils n'ont pas osé se faire des
examens parce qu'ils ont peur de choper
le coc vide dans les hôpitaux et merde
non allez faire vos examens aller faire
nos prises de sang parce que il ya plus
grave quelques fins
une connerie là que non mais je veux
dire le ya le cancer cayla qui est aussi
fort et il faut que les gens à et se
faire aller se faire dépister et de
faire c'est leur examen et jean-pierre
l'huile le truc parce qu'il ya dix j'ai
été tellement con de fumer plus de 40
ans pourtant je le savais que le cancer
des poumons existé mais j'ai fumé j'ai
fumé j'ai fumé et je pense que ça
n'arrive qu'aux autres c'est çà et là
bas non ça n'arrive pas qu'aux c'est
pour ça que c'est important qu'elles
n'ont pas c'est nathalie parce que ça
voilà voilà ça c'est saignant donne
raison alors vous avez dit que vous
l'avez vous l'aviez rien tout en disant
le mot cancer je me suis toujours battu
justement ça fait longtemps et jean
pierre conte à ce combat là j'avais
écrit des livres dessus que le mot
cancer je ne veux pas que ce soit à bout
moi j'en ai marre quand j'entends au
trésor ou au 20 heures il est mort d'une
longue maladie bordel de merde c'est pas
c'est pas une maladie contagieuse il
faut dire les choses comme elles sont et
voilà donc avec jean car de toute façon
on en parle ce soir je suis venu ce soir
c'est parce que bah ça s'ébruite en ce
moment je sais donc c'est pour ça que je
suis venu là ce soir sinon on a le
reportage on l'avait bien préparé avec
jean-pierre ça devait pas se dire ce
soir j'avais vous vouliez pas en parler
sinon c'est beau c'est parce que vous
avez vu que ça s'ébruite et il a dit oui
parce que jean piat ne pouvait pas venir
ce soir donc
donc il m'a dit baba zinat parce que
bien sûr dans les réseaux oui elle vient
pour pour faire parler d'elle voilà les
gens c'est important que vous ne pouvez
pas venir ce soir que vouliez que ça
comme l a vu que ça brille c'est sur les
réseaux vous a dit je préfère expliquer
moi ce qui se passe et on en est plutôt
que de voir tout n'importe quoi est
exactement à dire les choses comme elles
sont et voilà de toute façon ça va être
dévoilée ben on voulait pour le 9
décembre
belles choses mais c'est vrai que j'ai
vu j'ai vu j'ai vu déchets vu des tweets
envoyés ou pas de gens qui disent oui
mais là franchement je me suis toujours
gardé deux tweeté sûreté pmp mais là je
sors de mes gonds voilà il ya des
limites à la course à l'audimat mais
quel rapport keith associative c'est
hicham nazzal un ancien animateur de
france télé qui doit être à la recherche
de travail
non mais c'est vrai mais qui parce qu'il
a non mais juste aujourd'hui nathalie on
n'a personne la force à venir ou l'a pas
forcé à venir on l'adoré vous savez que
et jean pierre et nathalie c'est
vraiment la famille on les aime
aujourd'hui nathalie elle voyait plein
de choses sur les réseaux sociaux elle
voyait plein de choses plein d'articles
sur des voiles à des sites qui étaient
pas tous ne sont pas toujours sérieux et
la télé si je préfère venir dire moi ce
qui se passe actuellement pour
jean-pierre le dire une bonne fois pour
toutes qui renvoie là où on en est
plutôt que de voir écrit tout et
n'importe quoi et avec l'accord de mon
mari parce que voilà exactement il
raconte elle va venir sans l'accord de
son mari mort quand on repense c'est ce
à quoi non mais vraiment non mais oui on
attendait des sit in non seulement c'est
sa femme est elle même elle s'en remet
contre la maladie donc elle est très
légitime pour en parler moi j'ai une
question pour nathalie et jean pierre
c'est un jeune retraité mais qui
travaillaient encore beaucoup il fait
encore de la télé il fait encore son
journal est ce que la découverte de
cette maladie ça lui a donné envie de se
calmer professionnellement ou au
contraire de se lancer de nouveaux défis
je pense que les nouveaux défis ça lui
ferait pas peur parce qu'au contraire ça
ça lui changer les idées et c'est
important
tant qu'il peut bien sûr par contre moi
c'est peut-être moi qui vais un peu le
freiner pour dire non frais que tu te
reposes un peu mais sinon toutes les
choses qu'il a en ce moment ils
continuent à les faire bon il va se
coucher un peu plus tôt et celle plus
tard salle assez sale avantage de vous
avez peur aujourd'hui nathalie
si je vous dis non ça sera mon assurance
et ça serait un mensonge bien évidemment
que j'ai peur mais
on fait confiance aux médecins
maintenant aussi il est tombé sont des
médecins fabuleux les hôpitaux sont
enfin voilà ce extraordinaire il ya des
machines extraordinaires il ya des
progrès vraiment dans la dans la
médecine qui sont formidables donc
donc pourquoi on s'en sortirait pas
c'est quoi votre attitude au quotidien
on vous en parlait pas du tout ah si si
si sinon si tu de temps en temps mais à
quoi je le vois un peu tousser ou parce
que malheureusement ce qui va se passer
aussi c'est que avec les rayons à tout
moment il va avoir une cote qui va se
fêler donc c'est ça que je crains parce
que cela va être des douleurs mais
voilà si on en parle de temps en temps
on après on parle d'autre chose bien
évidemment bien évidemment c'est normal
mais mais vraiment il est il un
caractère de dengue quoi aussi alors je
suis très fier de lui comme toujours et
ouais ouais oui mais il est à moi je la
dois emblème cher si fiers dé l'histoire
donc encore un nouveau combat pour tous
les deux en fait oui comme voilà ça
n'arrête pas il a eu beaucoup de chance
parce que il n'ya pas longtemps
justement je dis ça au public aussi
c'est très important il y avait une
petite boule ici un bouton kg gratter
juste ici c'est après sont en opération
dit c'est bizarre j'ai eu c'est
peut-être un poil qui repoussait à
l'intérieur et tous et je suis bête va
faire quand même analyse et on sait
jamais ben heureusement parce que
c'était un prêt cancer aussi donc on n
hésitez pas à les voir alors on va tenir
matin aussi vous avez annoncé la
nouvelle aux enfants comme nous l'avait
dit c'est toujours un moment très
délicat on voit ce qu'en disent regardez
loup et comme on aime fort si on perd je
sais que le jour où il l'a appris on
s'était vus et alors il me l'a
absolument pas dit ben oui juste les
résultats ils sont pas tip top
ok et là c'est ma mère qui nous prend à
bahreïn dit oui du coup la terre un
cancer ah bah c'est sympa de prévenir
maman parce que je peux pas pas le dit
pas je vais faire un câlin et
et ses doubles je sais pas trop encore
ce moment là on n'a pas trouvé
si j'avais une question pour vous
nathalie rond voix jean-pierre parler
dans le reportage en in avec beaucoup de
distance et beaucoup de force de
caractère mais en off comment ils
appréhendent cette maladie et son combat
battle jeudi il a des hauts et des bas
ce qui est normal
après je pense qu'il veut pas non plus
m'effrayer donc on essaye de de prévoir
nos vacances voilà on parle de vacances
on a hâte d'être au bord de l'eau par
exemple on parle des études de nos
enfants
là on a envie de déménager d'avoir une
nouvelle maison donc on a deux plein de
projets donc voilà on voit on voit là on
voit la vie qui continue quoi surtout
surtout céder vos projets c'est surtout
ça oui et les enfants y sont ils sont
encore plus présents
malheureusement comme il à lille mais
souvent lui il a eu au téléphone et on
voit de temps en temps si on va pas
alors tu vas me alors que son ami dit de
téléphoner donc je trouve ça touchant
gib.a merde il pourrait aussi m'appuie
mois maintenant que pour le père où elle
est là elle est comment lankais loubet
louait les garder un peu pour elle quand
même jour un peu fofolle mais je sais
que c'est elle a un coeur comme ça et
peut-être que dans son lit je sais pas
et sont ils peuvent peut-être chacun de
leur côté ça je n'en sais rien mais je
pense qu'ils ont confiance aux siens à
la médecine est bon ils ont l'habitude
malheureusement d'être baigné dans le
cancer car ça c'est fou c'est c'est
voilà donc malheureusement ils sont
habitués à bien sûr jean pierre qui a
déjà vécu un cancer on l'avait dit de la
prostate et leur mère en 98 battu
récemment voilà donc le frère de
jean-pierre aussi et puis et puis des
amis très proches et comme on dit
jean-pierre voilà baiona ya 20 ans le
cancer à 30 ans à 40 ans voilà bon bah
ça tourne sur jean-pierre il est connu
mais allez vous faire dépister
n'attendez pas quoi n'attendez pas que
certains cancers du sein de la prostate
des poumons allez vous arrêter de fumer
dans le terreau eurent tout je voulais
vous dire que si réaliser un témoignage
il va y en avoir quelques-uns mais une
grande majorité de gens vont me trouver
formidable votre témoignage c'est un
témoignage d'amour dont jean-pierre
aussi d'amour pour tous les gens qui
vont combattre côté et c'est vrai que
chez vous il ya une force de caractère
qui est incroyable on dit toujours dans
ces cas là qu'il faut avoir un moral
d'acier et je pense que votre mental il
va être très important pour lui pour
toute la famille parce que vous êtes une
combattante quoi donc je voulais vous
dire toute mon admiration c'est gentil
data news
nathalie aujourd'hui donc voilà il est
en réseau pierre est traité on attend
donc la fin du traitement c'est qu'on
pouvons imposer la terminer la
radiothérapie d'accord c'est pour
l'instant parce qu'il avait plusieurs
séances on est obligé de
d'attendre pour voir comment s'est agi
parce que la radiothérapie agissent sur
un long terme et
donc en janvier on saura on va refaire
un pet scan pour savoir où ça en est
juste nathalie on sait que vous avez dit
souvent des dons on l'a vu même vous
avez participé à apprendre l'essai avec
moi j'ai gagné une très grosse boîte
mail on rigole mais c'est vrai que
nathalie parie que vous aviez eu un
pressentiment oui moi je qu'est ce que
s'est passé normalement c'est vrai que
je devais venir ce pour faire la
promotion de son livre mais je me suis
dit c'est pas du tout le moment parce
qu'on va vous reviendrez
justement je parle de mes rêves
prémonitoires donc je fais beaucoup de
rêves prémonitoires qui a sauvé
énormément mon mari déjà plusieurs fois
et puis là c'est vrai que avant d'avoir
le verdict pour le cancer des poumons
j'avais fait que ça se réalise toujours
en cauchemar
donc je fais un cauchemar et je rêve
qu'elle jean-pierre et mon fils dans une
voiture et qui est un camion que l'on
rentre dedans et je vois pas du tout mon
fils mais je vois mon mari qui était
rempli de suis je me réveille en sursaut
le coeur qui palpite je suis là à ce
moment là tellement que je transpire je
suis allé prendre une douche et
donc dès que je me réveille le matin
j'écris toujours sur un tableau dans la
cuisine mais mes rêves premier temps où
je sais qu'il va se passer quelque chose
et à ce moment là jean pierre et tom et
c'était parti en fait mon fils faisait
de la f4 donc il était parti faire une
course de bagnoles d'accord et la
j'appelle jean pierre j écoute j'ai fait
un cauchemar quand tu reviens
je sais plus où c'était surtout on roule
doucement parce que j'ai fait un mauvais
cauchemar et j'aime pas du tout ça quand
tu nous fais monde d'accord t'inquiète
pas je vais rouler doucement donc une
fois qu'il est arrivé à la maison je
fais ouf c'est pas ça j'ai dit mais il
ya quelque chose de grave je sais pas ce
qui va se passer jean carmet à quelque
chose de grave ça va être sur toi ou tom
mais je te vise plus toi eh ben le
lendemain on a eu le pronostic du du
résultat comme quoi c'est un cancer des
poumons et ensuite donc il a été guéri
du premier cancer fin du mois de juillet
ça a été guérie et au mois d'août je
fais de nouveau un cauchemar où il ya
les feuilles d'automne qui tombe et je
vois et je vois jean pierre je dis merde
il ya quelque chose qui va qui va se
passer en moi dauphin au moment où il va
voir l'automne il ya un truc qui va se
passer et donc j'en parle à jean-pierre
je suis pas bien il ya un mauvais signe
pour pour quelqu'un de la famille et
pour le mois d'octobre
eh ben le premier jour de l'eau 2
octobre on a appris pour son cancer du
poumon de l'autre côté et puis j'ai fait
des rêves tellement prioritaires j'ai eu
là la date exacte de la mort du frère de
jean-pierre par exemple bamba il avait
le cancer du foie le frère à jean-pierre
et et jeudi écoute jean pierre j'ai fait
un cauchemar sur ton sur ton frère je
voyais en costume noir et il va partir
le 3 novembre et là jean-pierre il sur
le coup il s'est un peu énervé il m'a
dit mais comment tu peux me dire ça et
tout je t'écoute je préfère te dire les
choses tu sais comment c'est à dire oui
mais je travaille j'ai pas le temps je
dis me dis pas ça prend le temps pour
ton frère parce que tu vas le regretter
il fait bon d'accord je fonce à amiens
je vais aller voir donc le 2 il a été le
voir à bien et reprend sa voiture le
soir ils étaient heures 23 heures et en
roulant jean-pierre il m'appelle il dit
vas tu vois dans une heure on est le 3
et mon frère est toujours là
heureusement tonton cauchemar ne se
réalise pas il rentre à la maison son
frère est décédé à 00h03 le 3 novembre
donc voilà j'ai eu la date de la mort de
mon jardinier aussi j'ai eu voilà plein
de trucs les accidents sur mon fils en
voiture j'ai eu voilà plein de
pressentiment après des pressentiments
où je savais qu'il fallait qu'il aille
voir pour son pour son coeur où on
s'était pris la tête pendant six mois et
jusqu'au jour j des coudes soit tu veux
avoir ton cardiologue où je prends mes
valises et je me casse et il fait bon
d'accord d'accord donc il a été voir son
cardiologue et puis là il a dit à votre
âme bien eu raison parce que vous avez
l'artère principale qui est bouché à
plus de 98 % c'est-à-dire en trois jours
là il fallait vite qu'ils se mettent les
semaines au coeur enfin voilà j'avais
encore sauvé la vie